Well, if I say I have an idea, it's more than enough, but I wonder if
it's okay
for me to
tell you about it.
You know that the family is divided into a head family and a branch family.They used to have
a strict master-servant relationship, but there was a big feud between them
.  In order to take responsibility for a certain problem that occurred between Tadashi and Tadashi, the twin brother Hijikata of the branch
family became the victim of the head family.
[MUSIC]
No way,
that was a sacrifice made by Hishiko-san himself.
Hiyashi-san turned his heart into a demon and tried to continue to
be a strict pitcher.  I think that I've made you live a hard life,
and I'm going
to attack Grandpa with Neji
[Music]
There shouldn't be a solution by suppressing it with force and fear
I'm sure
he has a reason for that,
so please
look at him a little more.